[Music]
[Applause]
well hello friends uh Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know uh we're delighted that you decided
to join us today for our program
uh I just want to reiterate that uh it's
important for you to send us your
questions I'm going to give you the
address the electronic address TVM
tv.org once again
TVM tv.org uh We crave your questions
because we do the research and uh then
we do everything possible to answer the
question on the air uh I want to also uh
mention that many times the question
questions are not answered immediately
because we have so many questions that
come in that we put them in order uh to
answer them according to the order in
which they came in uh so I have with me
Pastor David Salasar who is in charge of
our Spanish work but he's a um Jack of
all trades and a master of
all not all of us and uh so thank you
for joining us and we want to have a
word of prayer we always pray before we
begin the program uh so would you please
please pray for us absolutely
Heavenly Father we thank you for
allowing us to come before your throne
of grace and for giving us the
confidence that we can come boldly
before you to ask according to your will
and Lord it is your will to bestow upon
us your children the understanding of
your word and you have promised that the
Holy Spirit can come to those that ask
and we so we ask humbly that you will
send the Holy Spirit to speak to us and
through us so that we may be able to
share from your word an answer that will
bring people
closer to you and I pray all of these in
Jesus name amen so we have a very hot
potato question to start out with today
yes you might as well start out on the
right foot right right indeed uh so what
is the question that somebody has sent
us all right we have a question and it's
a interesting question it says the
following it's a tough question he
actually agrees with that and I think
has several parts but the question is
this um in the region where he where
this individual is the local Spanish
conference has been pushing for worldly
Progressive agenda it started with music
than women pastors they are circling
those this woman Pastor to get the local
churches used to it same tactics as the
world recently several churches have now
also adopted female Elders it's hard to
find a church that stays true to the
word of God nowadays I also live
paycheck to paycheck but stay true to my
tithe how can I give my tithe without
funding this political agenda the only
seems to go contrary to the word of
God some pastors say this is God's
problem let him handle it and that we
should give blindly if this is the case
do we also give when local churches
impose the Sunday law how is one
Justified but not the other so as you
said pastor this is a hot potato uh it's
a hard question it has a lot of things a
lot of parts and I think we should start
breaking it down you know uh with by
Parts I think the first question he has
is with the music uh or the celebration
of the type of adoration that we are
having in churches and so what can we
say about that Pastor and then we'll
continue from there well first of all
open
apostasy never happens overnight mhm it
begins with things that appear to be
small and
insignificant then it goes on to things
that are more significant and it ends up
like this individual says what happens
if a local church imposes a Sunday law
yeah uh but it starts out with other
things where we uh where we are not
faithful to the word of God uh for
example he mentions
music uh there is no doubt whatsoever
that um Satan has softened up mhm many
of our churches by introducing worldly
music right the fact is that music
Styles such as rock
disco um rap uh you know all of these
different styles of music that have come
in since the beginning of the 20th
century uh those styles of music were
prepared for worldly music they were
never prepared for church music they
were prepared for worldly music so uh
they say well you know if you attach
holy words to that music then it
sanctifies the music itself but that's
not the case because Ellen White says
that music itself has an effect Upon Our
physiology and Upon Our Minds right not
only the lyrics but also the music she
says that music certain kinds of music
can make young people not desire Christ
and that supposedly is is religious
music right so uh the devil he knows
that he's not going to be able to
convince the church to start keeping
Sunday as his first step of course not
so he he'll go to music he'll say well
you know that's a cultural thing and
then he'll go to the ordination of women
well you know that's a cultural thing
and then uh you know he takes it in
steps until eventually there is open
apostasy and you never discerned it
because it's like the frog in the kettle
that adapts to its environment
and it ends up being cooked yeah
inadvertently and so the devil never
works overnight MH he works long range
yeah because he knows that if he can
lead the church step by step away from
the
word the result will be open apostasy at
the end and Pastor that's the key as you
mentioned leading us away from the word
of God leading Us in practices in uh
Concepts in
even ideas that are slowly but surely
step or leading us in a direction that
is contrary to scriptures and so with
this music that these individuals
mentioning unfortunately we have seen
this very powerful movement around the
world that has invited has brought
worldly music to our sanctuaries to our
churches and sadly that creates is the
beginning or one of the early stages of
ladance in a direction that goes
contrary to God and now the second part
is you mentioned there the concept of
women pastors now he mentions that there
has been these um you know female Elders
elected and I know this is uh something
that it's not necessarily a pastor yet
but is is been has been pushed in many
places around the world to be uh okay
with the concept of electing Elders
women Elders to the office now let let's
expound a little bit on this why is this
also a situation that is is slowly but
surely leading us in a direction
contrary to scriptures well you know uh
if I could just make another remark
about music before we transition to this
um in 1900 there was a very famous camp
meeting that took place in Muny Indiana
the Indiana camp meeting yeah uh the the
conference personnel and the P many of
the pastors had embraced a theology
which is totally contrary to scripture
holy flesh the idea that uh you know
when you're converted you suddenly have
holy flesh well Ellen White corrected
the theological idea she said no we
won't have holy flesh until this uh
corruptible is transformed into
incorruption at the second coming of
Christ um but accompanying that
theology was a music style and in
selected messages volume two pages uh 30
uh I think it's 35 to 45 yeah Ellen
White took serious issue with the music
mhm with the theology as well but with
the music right now at that time there
was no Jazz right there was no Rock
there was no disco there was none of
these uh styles of music that have come
into the church these days and yet she
she condemned the use of that music
which was more like uh marches by John
Philip Souza at that time it was the
style of worship of the of the uh um
what do you call it the
um Evangelical well it was actually the
style music of the um oh I'm trying to
remember the the organization but anyway
it was a style of music that we would
consider tame these days of course
compared to the music that is being
introduced into the church today by the
way it's the Salvation Army oh it's not
one of the more more famous uh
denominations but it was their Style
music in fact I've written an entire
article on that particular camp meeting
and also I address it in my book worship
at Satan's Throne which is uh you know
an extremely important issue the issue
of music because it bypasses the uh the
locations of Reason in your mind and
goes directly to your emotions correct
um so so you know you can't say that any
kind of music that comes into the church
is all right um now back to the issue of
the ordination women pastors yeah it's
contrary to scripture the Bible says
that the Elder and we use the same
passage for ordinations of pastors needs
to be the husband of one
wife now is that clear enough that uh
that the Elder needs to be male he needs
to be husband of one wife of course it's
clear but then they say well that's
cultural you know that's was from that
time that was a patriarchal society all
kinds of arguments are used to overturn
the clear explicit meaning of the text
and uh and so that's another place where
we give a little in an area that we
don't consider to be particularly
theologically important but that leads
to another step and to another step
until eventually you're you're
disobeying God's will in many large
areas and you don't even notice it
because you become accustomed to culture
and this is actually something that we
can see before our eyes if you actually
look at a lot of the individuals
and those who have embraced the concept
you know even even not only in our
denomination but in other denominations
who have embraced the concept of
ordaining pastors disregardless
scriptures I mean women pastors
scriptures you can see that their path
is eventually disregard even more and
more solid scripture because you have to
start interpreting the Bible with your I
don't know with a with a
Progressive concept of thinking or a
secular concept of thinking where you
start interpret scriptures according to
what you think it has to say not what
the bible really says so it it's just
it's just natural for you to get to the
next stage of apostasy yeah the bottom
line is that women's ordination did not
come into the Adventist Church because
our Scholars said well let's sit down
and see what the Bible has to say about
the ordination of women uh they did that
but really the or origins of it is the
equality movement mhm in society in
culture right and so it came to the
point where we said you know we're
considered odd because you know culture
says that men and women not only are
equal as persons but they have equal
roles uh and so you know the church
needs to do something about this and so
there was uh you know a movement that
began in the church to try to adapt to
culture right and in some places the
same thing has happened with gay
marriage right there are Adventist
churches that are very uh lean very
supportive to the idea of gay marriage
uh and that was the next step after
women's ordination and the scary part is
as this person mentions will this
eventually lead to some Churches EMB ad
embracing Sunday as a day of worship you
know that would be the end of the
process and that's where Satan is moving
towards yes you know these preliminary
things although they're more moral and
they involve biblical principles and
spiritual prophecy principles are only
the first stage of Satan trying to get
the church adapted to smaller things
right uh so that that the church will be
unfaithful in larger things Jesus said
he who is faithful in little will be
faithful in much he who is Unfaithful in
little will be unfaithful in much and
that has proven true throughout the
course of the history of the Christian
church and we have seen sadly
these experiences there's evidence of
churches who were once Adventists who
were once part of their denomination who
have come to the conclusion that they
need to embrace Sunday worship to keep
themselves in a relevance with a
community and of course by doing that
you know forsaking our doctrines as as a
whole so it's not just something that
could happen we've seen happen in a
couple of experiences or cases in around
the world so we know that this is
something happen now Pastor his question
also comes to this important
part what about Tiding you know I think
he does mention the concept of tithing
as he says uh you know are we to uh
continue to give tithing to this you
know I guess church or my local church
if they continue with this political
agenda and will I have to continue to
give tithing even when they cons you
know con you know continue into the
Sunday law so what can we say about that
because I think there a question that he
needs to be addressed or answered as
well the bottom line is that other
people's
unfaithfulness does not justify our
unfaithfulness yes the bottom line is
that you know many times people are
tempted to say you know my tithe is
going to a conference that is promoting
all of these uh this worldly music and
this uh worldly entertainment and things
like that and they say in good
conscience I cannot return my tithe uh
in my local church to a conference that
has embraced that ideology yeah uh Ellen
White has some U some very interesting
statements yeah uh and maybe I can read
um a couple of them one of uh do you
have those there I have one pastor and
and you know it's important to answer
him because he's saying I was supposed
to give it blindly and I think that is
not to give blind L but I I'll let her
read and then maybe comment on that it
says some have been this this is
actually from testimonies volume 9 page
249 it says some have been dissatisfied
and have said I will no longer pay my
tithe for I have no confidence in the
way things are managed at the heart of
the work but will you rob God because
you think the management of the work is
not right make your complain plainly and
openly in the right spirit to the proper
ones send in your petitions for things
to be adjusted and set in order but do
not withdraw from the work of God and
prove Unfaithful because others are not
doing right so I think this is an
important counil you know she says three
things I mean to do you know first of
all if you see things not done run done
properly in your local church or
conference you
know you are to make your complaint
plainly openly in the right
spirit and to the proper people right
people you'll do that but that does not
mean that you withhold your tithes you
are to continue to give your tithes so
this idea of giving blindly is is not
really what he's saying you know so we
are to let our leaders know and let make
it open proper in the right Spirit to
the right people and then but we are to
continue supporting the church in spite
of or the local church you know in spite
of their mismanagement if you will you
know we have that advice we are to
continue so this is what I think you
know can help yeah one one of the
problems is uh in the church is that
people keep
quiet the members keep quiet they don't
protest yeah you know and uh Ellen
White's statement here is uh very clear
she says make your PL your complaint
plainly and openly mhm there principles
here in the right
Spirit to the proper ones in this case
if this is a conference philosophy that
is allowing things to happen in the
church in the churches then you need to
go to the conference MH and you need to
talk to the conference administrators
you know if they don't listen or pay
attention you've done your duty yeah
you've spoken up right uh and if there's
nothing more that you can can do you
need to pray that the Lord will set
things right in his way and in his time
right and sometimes God's methods are
pretty drastic yeah uh you know uh
there's another statement here uh from
uh Ellen White this is manuscript 31
1890 there's a whole uh historical
context to this yeah it has to do with a
constituency meeting in the Michigan
conference in August of
1890 uh where they were having great
problems Ellen White mentions that uh
ministers were dishonest licentious
doing little proper labor bringing the
work down and had no burden for Souls
yes that's the this case of the ministry
of the Michigan conference at that time
and she stated that those ministers who
failed to reform should be deprived of
their license or credentials yeah
otherwise the conference that has
sanctioned the labors of these men will
share their guilt so in other words
there's something to say about the
conference not doing anything about it
yeah but then Ellen White also wrote uh
in manuscript 3 you have been with you
who have been withholding your means
from the cause of God read the book of
Malachi and see what is spoken there in
regard to tithes and offerings cannot
you see that is not best under any
circumstances to withhold your tithes
and offerings because you are not in
harmony with everything that your
brethren Doh the tithes and offerings
are not the property of any man but are
to be used in doing a certain work for
God unworthy ministers may receive some
of the means thus raised but dare anyone
because of this withhold from the
treasury and brave The Curse Of God I
dare not Ellen White says I pay my tithe
gladly and freely saying as did David of
thine own have I have we given thee a
selfish with holding from God will tend
to poverty in our own Souls wow Act Your
Part my brethren and sisters God loves
you and he stands at the helm now here
comes the key portion you see the the
conference is guilty if it doesn't do
anything about it right and the church
member is guilty if they don't continue
returning their tithe uh she says this
at the end of this quotation if the
confence business is not managed
according to the order of the Lord that
is the sin of the Airing one the sin of
the conference in other words the Lord
will not hold you responsible for it if
you do what you can to correct the evil
that's speaking up but do not commit sin
yourselves by withholding from the Lord
his own property and so uh Ellen White
uh rebukes the
conference and she also rebukes the
member who does not speak up because
things are not being done in the church
as they should be done and Pastor that
is probably the you know the the answer
the right way to go about this situation
that we are called to stand for truth
but speak it in the right way in the
right spirit with the right people and
at the same time without us falling into
sin by withholding the tithe and the
offering that the Lord has you know told
us to give to turn return to him
and so you know I think that now in the
event that said individual it's seen or
is in a church that is embracing even
Sunday law or something like that you
know in that situation that would
probably become total apostasy for that
in that church and the congregation and
that at that time such person would have
to leave I mean there would not be
reason that church would be Babylon yeah
yeah without because one of the one of
the aspects of the wine of Babylon is uh
the Sun
right going worship on Sunday so uh you
know that would be that would be the
final step open apostasy against God and
then you would have to wonder whether
returning your ties to a church like
that uh would would be productive
because you would be supporting right
apostasy AP full apostasy so in that
scenario which is not if has happened at
least not in any Collective way maybe
individual churches that we mentioned
there have been examples of individual
churches following that pattern but and
the conference has this Fellowship those
churches so it's not like they you know
they belong in the conference so we have
seen that there's not that stage of
apostacy yet and so we have to not try
to act upon something that could maybe
happen you know and thinking is already
here so we have to just remember that we
are at a stage where there is apostasy
unfortunately I mean that's not
something that is should be a surprise
but there's not open or it's not complet
process in the church and so it's still
it's God's Church and because of that we
have to be faithful to what the council
has been given to us in in remaining
faithful in returning ties and offerings
but also in doing our part to let those
individuals that are in charge know in a
good and great spirit what they're doing
you know that need to be adjusted and
changed and you know the example of
Israel is very appropriate here um you
know they step by step by step uh were
LED away from God's truth and the the
eventually uh the cup was full mhm and
they they went to Babylonian captivity
uh so you know the Adventist Church has
taken certain steps which are
worrying uh but the church is not
Babylon Ellen White makes that very very
clear right uh neither the church has
gone beyond the point of no return uh
that's why we need to speak up and we
need to make sure that uh that the
church remains on the road that God
wants it to be on the straight and
narrow
and and the Lord has raised up people
individuals even Ministries such as ours
to um help people to stand in the truth
in the word of God and be able to be
lights in their churches in their
conferences to help them you know keep
our faith and the faith of God the Faith
of Christ alive and and and express and
share the gospel the good news of
Salvation to the world yes well we hope
that this discussion has been held ful
uh in clarifying some issues the bottom
line is let's not be unfaithful amen
because there are churches in
conferences that are Unfaithful yeah God
is going to set things right yes and
many times the measures will be drastic
uh so let's stay on course let's be
individually faithful let's speak up and
to the conferences uh in the world make
sure that you follow God's will uh in
everything thank you for joining us God
bless you hope to see you next time
[Music]